my name is Mark Montero I'm the founder
of lcg auctions we specialize in
high-end pop culture Collectibles today
we're going to talk through five
Collectibles ranging from $3,000 to
[Music]
$60,000 this is the very first Super
Mario Brothers released on the Nintendo
Entertainment System this particular
example would appraise for around
$10,000 this is a rare hang tab Edition
the back of it has a hang tab that's
perforated which is different from the
subsequent models that came out and
collectors find the Hang tab very
collectible this one is graded by cgc
which is also a comic book grader
they've graded some of the most valuable
comic books anything 9.0 or greater is
considered exceptional condition Super
Mario Brothers is the most popular video
game of all time there's been over 40
million copies sold Super Mario Brothers
revived the video game industry after
Atari the video game console was
starting to fail when the Nintendo
entertainment system came out Mario in
particular it created a whole new level
of Interest the Holy Grail of Super
Mario is a 9.8 sealed hang tab Edition
it's sold for $2
million this is a Sega Game Gear
released in 199 91 it's the very first
release retailed at
$149.99 at launch this is around
$12,500 this example is what we call
Hobby fresh it's never gone to Market
before and it'll be interesting to see
where it ends up this grade is the Holy
Grail of Sega Game gears it's graded by
VGA it's a VGA 85 Game Gear was sega's
answer to Nintendo's Game Boy the game
boy was black and white the Sega Game
Gear was in color unlike game Game Boy
you could actually play Game Gear in the
dark because of the backlit screen the
Sega Game Gear had popular titles like
Sonic the Hedgehog and Streets of Rage
over 10.5 million units were sold of the
Sega Game Gear it was one of the most
popular portable gaming systems for
years the Sega Game Gear is known for
ripping through batteries but there was
also a TV tuner that you could put on
the top allowed you to watch television
stations on the portable
console this is the very first release
of Ghostbusters on VHS from 1985 it
retailed for
$79.99 $79.99 was a very high price but
BHS was in its infancy and the tapes
were just very high it's dropped down a
bit but it's still in the four figures
the first edition Ghostbusters has some
unique features the logo on the front is
an embossed logo on the back it also has
what we call waterfall watermarks these
are vertical RCA White Water marks that
resemble a waterfall VHS as a
collectible is relatively new in the
four and five figure numbers some video
tapes that have sold for a lot of money
include Superman blackbox Edition this
was a betamax tape that sold for
$40,000 and some of the early release
Rockies have sold for significant
amounts of money as
well this is an Apple iPod first release
first generation from October 2001 one
it retailed for
$399 the last one that sold sold for
$229,000 the first edition iPod is
extremely rare in Factory sealed
Condition it's become highly collectible
Through The Years in Collectibles we
have something called scarcity just
because something is rare doesn't make
it collectible scarce factors in demand
so something scarce is often times
collectible this is most definitely the
Holy Grail iPod the first release the 5
GB version and Factory sealed it has a
black and white screen it utilizes
buttons as opposed to a click wheel and
it stores around 1,000 songs Apple had
been struggling up until the early 2000s
and this was the first handheld device
that really helped the company turn a
corner and it really launched Apple's
handheld division to new
heights this is the first release iPhone
from 2007 this model cost
$599 we have it between 50 and
$60,000 this model's 8 GB for the
internet it used something called The
Edge Network it was a very slow internet
service and that was kind of the main
difference for this first model compared
to the subsequent models Factory sealed
means the seal has not been broken it's
not been opened up you may have an
iPhone at your house and think it could
be worth a lot of money the reality is
it's probably not there's a lot of them
in the population and for that reason
they're not worth very much Steve Jobs
introduced the phone at Mac World in
January 2007 there was a lot of hype
around it the most expensive item that
that we have sold is a first release
iPhone from 2007 it was the rare 4 gab
model the 4 GB was discontinued after
just 2 months in and it went for
$190,000 an item that would just be a
Holy Grail that we have not seen if we
were to have an unopened iPhone with a
signature from Steve Jobs the sky would
be the limmit on something like that
I've heard that he actually gave
assigned addition iPad to his inner
circle there are counterfeits that enter
the market from time to time collectors
have to be very careful to make sure
that all sides of the iPhone are shown
the seal follows a very detailed pattern
the use of the box underneath the seal
it should be in mint condition the seams
along the side are very thin those that
are resealed the counter Fitters never
tend to get the seal
[Music]
right my advice to those looking to get
into Collectibles is to collect what you
like do your homework in terms of
pricing previous sales history some of
the stuff is very very expensive so you
want a good amount of knowledge before
you dive
in